welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host hisham azuz and on
this week's episode i was joined by tom
froggett who's worked in recruitment for
over 10 years for the last three and a
half years he's been building his own
recruitment business called singular
talent and in this episode we really dug
deep into how he's successfully climbed
the ranks in companies like s3 how he's
become a success in not just the uk
market but also american new york
markets and we really broke down over
the last three and a half years how
despite kovid despite it being just him
smashing in deals he's now really
excited about growing the company and
they're a team of eight at the moment
there's some really exciting things
ahead enjoy the episode tom welcome to
the podcast thank you for having me good
to be here thanks for uh making the trip
yeah yeah no worries no worries good job
now now live in
obviously i spoke to you quite early on
in your business journey
and i think obviously you moved your
whole family to
cardiff yeah that's right where did you
live before we were living out in surrey
in regate uh and i was working not far
from here actually uh in liverpool
street yeah yeah it's a complete life
change yeah
yeah well as soon as we decided to start
the business um
i just didn't need to be in london
anymore yeah and we did i'm from
manchester my wife's from wales from
south wales where we live now
and um
the more i looked at moving there so
initially it was a personal thing and we
had little kids and that kind of stuff
but the more i looked at moving there
the more from a business point of view
cardiff just got more and more
attractive yeah yeah it's a great place
to be and
there's really good talent there there's
two really good universities
it's much cheaper than being
and you can just
you can build a business that stands out
a bit more there's so many businesses in
london that are really cool to work for
and they've got really great spaces and
they've got really good cultures and
things like that
if you go elsewhere it's a little bit
easier to stand out yeah yeah yeah
thanks for making the trip sure no
worries and uh where where we always
like to to start
is is the million pound question really
and i'm probably something you've really
thought long and hard now for your own
business so i'd love to sort of hear
your perspective on what common
characteristics and traits a successful
modern day recruiter has and the things
that you look for
yeah it's interesting because it's
changed a lot since
16 years ago when i got into recruitment
i think
you get all types so there's not like a
personality type i don't think or a
profile that you'd look for but i think
there are some core characteristics i
think some things haven't changed i
think this is still a difficult job and
you still need to be determined and
resilient and
self-motivated and all that kind of
stuff
but i think what has changed is that um
it's still a sales job it used to be a
more hardcore sales job and so you were
looking for people who were
really target driven really money
motivated really wanted to to sort of
take as much as they could for
themselves
i think now what makes more effective
recruiters is
people who are really interested in
other people and helping other people
and helping them with their career and
understanding them and getting to know
them and so
that's become
a big part of what we look for
the other side of it is that we used to
do everything by phone
now so much of your communication
especially when you first get in touch
with a candidate or a client is written
they've got to be able to write
they've got to be able to write
persuasively and engagingly and and we
do we actually started doing like a
little written test as part of our
interview for that yeah
um
so yeah i think i think driven and
motivated obviously
communication skills are really key and
you just got to want to help people and
get a good result for the people you're
working with on both sides of the fence
i think
where's the line was the helping people
part because
you see people talking about then it's
like
if you just want to help people in
recruitment then you're in the wrong job
i've seen some people say i don't know i
just feel like there's that line of like
you can be motivated by that but yeah
do you know what i mean well yeah no
it's good point i think the caveat i'd
give to that is that
wanting to help people is a good thing
but you want to you want people who want
to be the best at helping people like
you want people who who sort of
they have some pride about their own
performance they want to stand out they
want to be successful so i suppose
that's what i mean by the driven [ __ ]
you got to marry that with other things
if they just want to help people then
there are better jobs that they could be
doing right yeah
there's going to be loads of challenges
and
yeah recruiters aren't just perceived as
people that help people are they no
no
and but you know i i've always thought
or thought for a long time that actually
we're never going to get someone to take
a job that they don't want to take
they might say yes on the phone if we're
really good at selling it to them but
they're not going to turn up
and they're not going to do the job so
actually
all we're trying to do is help them make
the right decision for their career and
what gets in a lot of people's way with
their career decisions is
uncertainty and risk and fear and and
the unknown and all that kind of stuff
or thinking about emotionally rather
than thinking about it logically like
there's a lot of pride wrapped up in job
titles and salaries and things like that
but realistically what difference does a
grand a year make in your pocket
on a weekly basis
but you see people dig the heels in over
that
because it's all wrapped up with how
you're valued and how you perceived
right um so i i see a lot of what we do
as
helping people get out of their own way
to make the right decisions yeah i think
about it um
so
that combination is a combination as you
said so we're so
we're going to talk about your journey
of the last three in a bit yeah sure
we're going to definitely speak a lot
about that today but so you've worked
for multiple brands
leading up to the point of starting on
your own so i guess before we sort of
unpack some of that where i always like
to start is just because recruitment as
a career isn't something that
you always say descendants right people
don't grow up think about it uh it finds
people people fall into it who who was
tom before recruitment
how did it like where was you in your
life like yeah so i mean i joined um s3
straight after graduating so i did an
english degree
um and
really just went straight into
recruitment so your first like
professional first first proper one and
i was with that company for 10 years wow
okay i just got really lucky just landed
in the right place with the right people
i think but um
yeah it's interesting i've i've always
put since i started in recruitment i've
always put a huge amount of value on
hard work and and
you know putting in a shift and and
that being a really key element of why
i've been successful but that is not
what people who knew me before i got
into recruitment would have said
described you as nah
my uh i was remembering my a level
history teacher i went to see him after
i got my exams my exam results
i got an a in history but i got it by
one mark right and he said you know what
when those results come out i looked it
i thought that's typical frogger he's
just done enough just
um so he's quite quite described like
that to get through the academic system
was like tom would someone just get
enough to
do what he needs to do rather than like
you'll go above and beyond he's very
hard working
yeah no one would have described me like
that no the second part of what you said
so did that come once being in an
environment where you're like okay if i
if i'm going to be able to
achieve what maybe they told me that i
could achieve or looking at people
around me
i'm gonna have to be someone that
has some really good work ethic
yeah i think um
there's a few reasons for that i think
by the time i finished uni i was just
sick of having no money really so that
had an impact right i just wanted to
make some money um
as well
i was in a an environment where
everybody worked hard
and you know my first my first sort of
mentor manager
really instilled a lot of that work
ethic in me just by the how hard he
worked
is that how he did it because i
yeah yeah i mean you know but it wasn't
just him it was everyone else around you
as well but um
but yeah they obviously told you that it
wasn't a nine nine-to-five job and all
that kind of thing
that doesn't really land unless
you see it and you see people doing that
you can't give someone work ethic can
you no no
um but i think what it was was i you
know
i
found it challenging first of all so it
was like the right level of challenge
and it was hard enough that i was
interested in it and it kept me engaged
but it wasn't so hard that i couldn't
get my head around it
so i wanted to get better at it and i
was quite competitive as well so when
people were doing better than me i
wanted to catch up to them
um
and then there's no there's no real end
to it right you you just
realize that okay well if i do more of
this stuff then i'll do more deals
and actually the money was good but it
wasn't really about the money in the end
it was more about the fact that i just
went to beat everyone really i just
wanted to beat everyone and i found
something that i was good at and i'd
found something that i liked and i
decided i was going to be the best at it
and i just worked really hard how would
you describe the s3 culture
looking back why
why has it produced yeah so many
recruiting entrepreneurs
produced big numbers yeah high
performance obviously so many people
have come out of that business
yeah so i mean i can only comment on
what it was like it's been
five six years since i worked there and
i believe it's changed quite a lot but i
joined in 2006
and i was there till 2016.
and i think um
it was hard
but it was hard work the targets were
hard the hours were hard it was it was
competitive there was a high expectation
but you were you were sort of
you were really well rewarded for doing
well not just monetary
reward but but that was part of it but
there was always lunch clubs and
achievers lunches and holidays and
consult another month and consult
another week and little competitions and
all this kind of stuff and and you know
if you were doing deals i always
remember when i did my first deal
the top biller in the office coming over
to me and helping me put it on the board
i love that
and this was an office of like 50 people
so this wasn't like a small group
um and so there was real like
there was real support for you once you
um once you were in
and then you had to perform
i think
there's several reasons i think why it's
created so many entrepreneurs um i think
you're always encouraged to think like
that you know they always wanted people
to start new businesses internally and
they they put a lot of emphasis on the
mi scheme and
uh you know i went out and set up a
business in new york for them which was
me and one other guy and we built that
over a couple of years and and i think
that was always very well publicized
so um
so you were always given the opportunity
to like come to them with ideas if you
if you saw a market or you saw an
opportunity that was really encouraged
but i think as well they got down to an
absolute science how to run a
recruitment business
and it was a kpi driven culture and in
some teams that would be
used more effectively than others let's
say
um because i don't think kpis are
inherently a bad thing but that's second
i agree
um
but what it meant was that you knew
100 that if you wanted to do this much
business you had to speak to this many
candidates today yeah so if you wanted
to build this match this year you had to
call this many people today and and it
was really clear to me i don't know if
it was the same for everybody it just
made it really obvious that that's how
you'd be successful
and that's why they were able to
replicate it in so many cases really got
into the data
the numbers yeah then it's about
obviously what are we doing to make sure
that they are the right people in it the
quality is maintained
100 and again
some parts of the business were better
at that than others but it was a big
company that's always going to be the
way
um
i think the other thing that they did
really well and i didn't realize this
until i left was that they really taught
you how to sell properly really yeah
um
i think there's a lot of recruitment
businesses out there that teach you how
to recruit like how the process works
i don't know that there's always and i
don't know every recruitment company but
i don't know there's always that
emphasis on how to become a really good
salesperson
they were very good at that
and they promoted people really quickly
as well they gave you loads of
responsibility and gave you the
opportunity to succeed or fail
how how do they how do they invest in
making
helping you understand to become a
better salesperson just training
yeah loads of internal training lots of
coaching lots of role plays lots of like
team workshops
um
they had a whole you know they had an l
d department obviously and we used to go
off-site for training to the l d
department all the time
and then they'd have performance coaches
on the sales floor and things like
performance coaches yeah
um but i think as well a lot of the
management a lot of the leadership had
come from other sales jobs
like they've been selling advertising or
they'd been selling whatever could you
know there's loads of different types of
things
so i think that that
that view of the job as a sales job was
just really ingrained in in what they
did from the start and so they got the
science of it right with the kpis and
how you build a business and then they
got the sales bit right
and then they hired some brilliant
people
um
it was a you know there was times where
it was a pretty aggressive environment
in terms of how we sold but there were a
really good bunch of people that for the
most part and
um
i think that's why they were so
successful and then they were never
satisfied they never sat still
you know when they were in 10 countries
they wanted to be in 20 when they were
20 countries they wanted to be in 30
when they were doing too many and they
wanted to do five and in doing five they
wanted to do 20. you know it was always
moving forward it's relentless
why
she said about how competitive it was so
always curious
a lot of people listen to this who do
want to progress they do want to
open up new markets they want to be
given the opportunities like why was you
able to get those opportunities do you
think over other people well i asked for
them
and then i hit all the targets there to
hit so um
so i i basically went in to the london
business so we were really small life
science business it was mostly an it
recruitment company but we had two
people doing life sciences recruitment
and that was the third one
and so i suppose that cleared a lot of
space for me as well because there
wasn't many people ahead of me um
but i did all right in my first year and
my second year i did really well i was
totally in the uk
um and then at the beginning of my third
year i said they've been talking about
opening up a new york office and i said
i want to go
so they said okay well you've been top
below once go and do it again and you
can go
jesus all right
and i didn't i didn't quite i came third
the third year i think um
and but then what happened was we were
we were planning to go
and the person who was going to run that
business actually resigned
um so she had decided that she didn't
want to move to new york i think she was
she'd been running a big team and i
think she was finding it hard being
hands on again as well it wasn't really
what she wanted to do sure
um and so
i went into the director's office and i
said listen i know you're probably going
to bring someone in to do it i was a
senior consultant with two years
experience at the time but
i'm up for giving it a go if
like if you've not got anyone else in
mind then
you know once he'd stopped laughing and
recovered
i think they interviewed everybody they
could find and i guess no one wanted the
job so they let me take that opportunity
but
you have to perform first of all but
then
i think for me what always worked was
just asking for the opportunity i think
that's just that's just come up a lot
which i wanted to ask it because i think
sometimes that can be missed yeah i'm
sure you've had to deal with people that
i don't know you're having an exit
interview with them or they resign and
sort of you learn that like they were
hoping that things would come to them or
they'd expect
because i've done this that i would be
given this opportunity rather than
saying hey tom look if i do this
can you tell me like this is what i'll
get at the end of it or this is what we
can agree and i think that's a
consistent insight for people
where if you want clarity on
where you want to be or your progression
then
find out from people and ask that look
if i do this does that mean that i'll
then move to this part of my career and
move forward yeah
what so you then went to new york
how long was you there for two and a
half years
what was the the most challenging part
about that
professionally personally because as i'm
sure you picked up on
and we'll talk about your business in a
sec i don't know how much you're doing
the states now but like
crazy amount of recruitment companies
going over to
the us this is a bit of time we've got
now so yes this was 2010. yeah so i'm
sure that there's been a real trend over
the last couple of years yeah what yeah
what was the challenges what things do
you have to learn quickly over there i
mean i loved it in new york i think um
[Music]
if you live in london and you recruit in
london one of the easiest places you can
go is new york okay i think the the
there's not the same culture but they're
similar enough that that you don't have
to adapt quite as much but the biggest
challenges were nobody knew who we were
we had when we turned up on day one we
had 14 candidates on the database wow
and no clients
and we thought that's okay we've got
loads of clients in europe because we
had other offices at that point we had a
germany office and i think we might have
had a belgium office at that point so we
had like a decent sized business two
offices in the uk
like okay well we're you know we're
working with these five really big
speakers helping them in the us yeah so
so we did that and then basically they
all went nah separate you'll have to
speak to this person over there and we'd
bring that person over there and they'd
go oh you work with us in europe oh yeah
we've got our own suppliers we don't
care
um and so that whole plan that we had
about converting our clients just didn't
work at all wow eventually we ended up
working with some of them but it took a
long time so it was really starting from
scratch
where'd you even where did you even
start with that
like is it market mapping is going this
is the niche we're going to focus on
yeah i mean it was to be honest back
then it was speak to candidates find out
where they're interviewing yeah look for
job adverts follow them up see how
they're getting on with them and
cold call as many companies as we could
you know we had we had a really defined
niche we were working in the pharma
sector and we're working in two really
specialized markets so it's quite easy
to identify who we need to speak to but
yeah you just got to
pick up the phone and and do the work
but the other thing about the us is you
don't realize until you get there how
big it is
so we started out we were based in new
york well we're based in london first of
all during new york hours but then we
were based in new york and what we
should have really done
was just focus on like the tri-state
area new york new jersey philadelphia or
the other way
[Music]
we didn't do that we just tried to pick
up jobs whatever and we could yeah but
what happened was we were working a job
in north carolina
and then we'd pick up a job in texas
and that's i don't know what the actual
distance is but let's say that's like a
thousand miles away right it's
completely different candidate pool so
we're just starting from scratch on
every every time yeah i think
understanding that was important
um
[Music]
and also understanding i think this was
one of the big cultural differences in
the us so here if you call someone and
they don't want to talk to you they just
hang up on you
in the u.s a lot of the time like
they're a bit more
open to being called
or they were then anyway and so they'd
speak to you i just had this great
conversation you think i've got all
these leads we've got all these prospect
clients you'd never ever be able to get
all of them again because they would
just be nice
um so that's interesting yeah so that
was what was challenging about it
so and then do you do much in the us now
with singular only a little bit at the
moment
so it's only through existing clients
that we have but um certainly on the
agenda hey everyone a real quick one
from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincerie and sourcebreaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out vincerie who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
sourcebreaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products
so
let's segue into
you then evolving into
running and starting your own
recruitment business yeah
but i guess going into
making that decision i guess what would
be first good to get your thoughts on
was
what were
the things that were top of mind for you
that you're like you know what really
enjoyed that s3 i'm taking that
really really enjoyed this part of this
business like what were the key things
that you wanted to take that that you
then have really tried to instill in
your company or when you started your
company you wanted to
really try and instill yeah there was
definitely things that i wanted to take
with me and then there was there was
things that i wanted to do differently
and i think um you know i joined after
s3 i'd been there for 10 years i joined
a company called meet um m-e-t not
m-e-a-t i used to have to say that
and they were a business that spun out
of s3 a long time before so there was
some similarities but they've done a
really good job with their branding and
their culture and and they've done a lot
of really good stuff around that
so i think that that really opened my
eyes to how important culture and brand
and marketing in general are
so i wanted that to be and i got really
interested in that so i wanted that to
be a key part of what the business was
about
i also wanted to just do recruitment
properly i think um
you know we
it's it's easier to engage with people
now than it was 16 years ago and it's
easier to find them and it's easier to
contact them but that doesn't mean it's
easier to place them you know and i
think sometimes because it's easier to
engage people we we sort of rely on
volume a little bit i wanted to make
sure that those those sales skills that
i'd learned those relationship building
skills were part of it
and i put a lot of emphasis with my guys
now still on um
you know when you speak to a candidate
for the first time for example go and
talk to them about their career go and
have a conversation with them about
where they are what they're up to what
their ambitions are
try and help them out whether it's with
this job or not try to understand where
they're going and give them at least
leave them having
been living better off yeah before yeah
if that's insight if that's information
exactly or you've just asked them a
really good question that's gotten to
think about stuff
so i wanted to make sure that we weren't
just doing
the sort of
you know the the sort of internet
recruitment stuff that's a part of it
that's a really important sourcing tool
but we're keeping that human element to
it so is that when obviously on what you
have sort of plastered everywhere is
like i believe that hiring should be
better
is that what you mean by that then
to an extent yeah so that's that's a bit
more encompassing so that that whole
thing about making herring better is
really about the fact that i i really
genuinely think that if you're hiring
someone for your team or you're looking
for a new job that should be a really
exciting thing to do
um
but i mean you and i both know probably
most people since this podcast know that
it's that's not the word that most
people would use to describe it right
um
the
there's several reasons for that right
but a lot of it's down to process and a
lot of it's down to just different
priorities and all this kind of stuff
but i wanted to build a company that
helped to make hiring better for
companies and for people and i think you
know some of that is about effectiveness
obviously some of it's about helping
companies hire more effectively helping
people get the jobs they want but a lot
of it's about the experience and a lot
of it's about
how you can't always give people good
news on both sides but how do they feel
about it afterwards do they feel like
it's been beneficial if they have they
had the support they need i mean you
know that one of the biggest complaints
people have about recruiters is don't go
back to them and they can't get hold of
them when they've not got the job
um you know we we
would never tolerate that at singular
talent and i think um
one of the things i'm really pleased
about is we do we do candidate surveys
every month well like nps staff mps
pretty much yeah um and we obviously
speak to candidates we've placed but
most of them are going to give you a
good review so i send a survey out to
everyone we've had an interview for but
we didn't place whether they didn't get
the job or they pulled out of it or
whatever
and among those people
our nps score is 75. that's brilliant
which is which is phenomenal so these
are people who didn't get the job
through us but they felt that the
experience was valuable and i've had
people
who i've been speaking to that one of my
consultants has um has been working with
and i've been speaking to them because
it's been a tricky close or whatever
and they when they they've turned down
jobs but said i just want to say even
though i'm not taking i've been doing or
you've been ready they've been
absolutely
exactly yeah so let's just so
let's just take a step back for a second
then so what year did you start the
singular talent 2019 january 2019. okay
cool and then because i feel like when i
spoke to you
like the early of those stages
i felt like your mindset encrypt me from
wrong here your mindset was really try
and give the first year
a crack
build revenues get billing start
building yeah with clients and then i
feel like then when i spoke to you more
recently or over that what i've seen
sort of externally over the last three
six nine months it's then seemed a lot
more morphed into like you you've then
put a lot more effort into growing the
company and then focusing more on that
so when you
we had someone sit down here a couple of
weeks ago
and he just felt like one of the best
bits of advice he could give other
recruiting entrepreneurs was like when
you go on to that journey just have
clarity on what you want it to look like
yes from the outset yes because i'm sure
you've met those people who are like
i don't use the word like lifestyle
business but like and caught up on like
should i be hiring people is that what i
should be doing so how did you view it
because i feel like you've gone on a bit
of a journey so when you started
singular talent was you're like right
this is a complete i do want to grow
this is a company that's going to be
bigger than just myself yeah definitely
i mean i i spent a lot of time on the
business plan before i started the
company okay um
and
and when i say a lot of time i spent a
lot of time writing the business plan i
spent like years thinking about it
beforehand yeah um so
i i always wanted this to be a big
company and very very early in this
journey um and it was all centered
around this mission of making hiring
better and that was really important to
me
um
and
what i didn't want to do was just grow a
lifestyle business and then i'm not
knocking there's nothing wrong with that
you knew that isn't what you wanted
exactly and i was never worried that um
you know when you start a business
there's always things that worry i was
never worried that i'd be able to make
enough money to pay the bills like i
knew even if it was just me and my spare
room i could do that yeah um and we'd be
fine me and my family would be all right
the thing that kept me up was like am i
going to be able to grow this to the
scale that i want to grab
so that was always the plan but you know
when you start a business the first
thing you got to do is survive
and
we had i had personally six months worth
of cash
that's the runway that you gave yourself
yeah
i put 20 grand into the business
um 10 grand of it was mine 10 grand of
it was from a start-up loan that was it
yeah um and it was all perm recruitment
right so it took four months to the
first deal four months uh he then took
another couple of yeah well
our first client
yeah won't be listening to this
i'll mention it anyway he was a guy
called steve allen and he had started a
company called childhood molecular 20
years 20 plus years ago so he was a
founder as well
and he played my first invoice the day
that i sent him to him as class yeah and
i never told him i spoke to him about
this recently i never told him that it
was our first placement and i never told
him how early on we were but i think he
knew yeah he was around there
and when i spoke to him about it
recently
i mentioned that and he said yeah i i
always
remember i remember what it was like
yeah and i was actually visiting my mum
and dad in spain when i sent that
invoice so i sent it that morning and
then looked at the bank account the next
morning i was like oh my god 12 grand in
there
was that one of your best moments so far
yeah yeah well because we were
we were like two grand from the end of
the overdraft in the business at that
point and
we had an ex we had one more month's
worth of money but only because i'd had
a tax refund
um so like we were close what what were
you keeping an eye on or thinking about
to make sure you was confident that
you're doing the right things and that
moment was
gonna come yeah you know well i think
this is where the point in my career at
which i started the company helped me
because i'd run teams and i'd manage
people and and i had quite a lot of
experience with that
so i knew
what activities i needed what like the
lagging indicators were to get to that
yeah exactly and i i was really um
quite structured with like setting daily
targets and all that kind of stuff and i
you know i still to this day of like a
kpi tracker that i have on my desk and
it's now for the team rather than me but
it was just for me and i have a day
planning my diary and all that kind of
stuff so i was really structured with
all of that
so i knew it was coming
you just never quite know if it's coming
fast enough because you can't quite
control that bit what what were the
people listening to this might be in
that moment yeah what were the
what were the key indicators that you
were keeping a close eye on that you
wanted to make sure that you show up
each day and aim to hit or
what you're keeping on to go you know
what hopefully if like you said it's out
of your control but if we keep doing
this then yeah we should be in a
position where we're sending out
invoices in x period of time yeah well i
think i think particularly in any
permanent recruitment business right
it's there is a big lag so contract is a
bit more reactive and it's more about if
you've finished this project
but i've i've always said the perm
recruitment is just about doing the
right amount of the right things in the
right way every day and then you'll
eventually get the result of that and
you'll eventually get the consistent
output but
um i think the indicators are
you know did you add more jobs this
month than last month
are you covering those jobs did you book
more interviews
have you got more interviews going on
now than you had
there's always been like a rule of thumb
little equation that however many final
interviews you've got or final interview
shots you've got divided by two and
minus one and that's probably where
you'll end up in terms of deals so how's
your pipeline looking in terms of final
interviews that are happening
um
and i think you know it's not so much
about the sort of blanket kpis in terms
of well how many cvs did i send out this
week no but you need to know where
you're at and like what you need to be
aiming for that would give you
confidence that you're going to be where
you want to be yeah and before that
point you know you've got to break it
down to the things you can control so
you might not know in your business
today how many calls do i need to make
or how many meetings do i need to book
to pull the job you might not have that
information yeah but you've got to make
a bit of a guess at it and give yourself
a target and make sure you do that every
day yeah um simplify it and you've got
to be quite hard on yourself as well i
think this is what hold yourself
accountable yeah i think i've worked
with some founders of recruitment
companies who
don't do that and they let themselves
off the hook a little bit
and you know
most of the time they end up being all
right because they're usually good
recruiters but it takes them a lot
longer it's a lot more painful it's a
lot more stressful because they don't
know where they are
so i think
be like your own toughest manager in the
early days particularly because you've
got to fit it's hard to see the progress
sometimes but you've got to
make sure you're doing the right things
we've also got to look at where you're
making progress because otherwise it's
hard you're just going to sit in there
what so then when did you make your
first hire
well
because then obviously went into covered
vibes after that yeah yeah it was a bit
of a story with that so we
i did the first year on my own until i
think it was end of october and then i
brought someone in whoever then what was
the goal to like get revenue wise to
give you confidence and like right i'm
in a position to hire if you had well
that was a mistake that i made so i did
it based on the number of jobs that we
had and the fact that i couldn't cover
everything right okay we didn't really
have enough money in the bank to hire
someone and me not to be stressed about
it okay um so that put a lot of pressure
on that higher right
and look it turned out that it wasn't
the right fit anyway and all that kind
of stuff so they actually um they
actually left the business just before
the pandemic oh wow okay um so this was
in the february and i think that they
started in the march
but the plan had been
to build on that the plan i think was to
go to five in the second year and all
this kind of stuff but i hadn't done it
with any financial triggers
i've just gone i'm really busy i need
some help so it was more on like
traction on the job front and like
missed opportunities or you know if you
had someone and there'll be
opportunities that they can work on
straight away which should mean
yeah exactly but
i think that's the wrong way to do it
that's the way i did it but i think
that's the wrong way to do it um so
anyway so we that person left
i decided not to replace them straight
away because of that because we weren't
in that stronger financial position
and then the lockdown happened happened
yeah we just found out we're having
another baby as well oh wow um and so
like all my sort of financial plans just
went and you have no idea at that point
what's going to happen with this
pandemic of course yeah it was yeah is
this your thoughts gonna be six weeks
right so you know that's a bit of a blip
but
but i had like a big talent partnership
which is like our subscription model our
first one that was due to be signed on
the day the lockdown was announced wow
and the ceo rang me up and went
listen obviously i'm gonna have to park
this i can't commit to this right now
so that was that was
40 grands worth of business which at the
time was like a huge that was more than
you would have done in a month
at any point
um so so decided for that year just to
get my head down how do you deal with
that
with that who you like because who do
you speak to about that
was like do you not mean yeah well
that's i mean you know this but that's
one of the difficult things about
starting your own business is you
haven't got that person to vent to or
that person to tell you it's all right
what did you do on that day to do that
bad news i went and picked up the phone
and tried to pull more jobs
so you didn't i think that with that i
don't know that's what really helped me
like i can some
i'm sure you can find moments where
you're like just spiraling and you're
sitting there just going oh my god what
the [ __ ] and then what's always helped
me is what you just said is
taking action basically yeah that's what
sort of shift
me straight away into like okay right i
just need to get cracking there's no
point just sitting there going okay well
what am i gonna do now and spiraling and
just thinking about those things i mean
i had like so they announced the
lockdowns at like five o'clock in the
evening or something i remember like
pulling up outside my house and hearing
it on the radio and going oh this is
like serious yeah
and i i allowed myself to just panic for
about four hours
and then i went right there's no point
in panicking anymore i need to sort out
what i'm gonna do with this so i stayed
up that night until about two in the
morning figuring out like what am i
going to go and talk to people about
tomorrow what am i going to put on
linkedin what am i you know what's going
to be the the the angle that we're going
to take from this what so so i put
together like a really rough like remote
interviewing guide remote onboarding
plan all this kind of stuff and just
posted it everywhere i sent it to
everyone
went obviously and because it was the
day that the lockdowns have started i
know everyone's done that now right but
and i did nick a few things but um
it was just really timely and it was
just it just received what i was
proactive yeah and i wasn't trying to
sell them something i was just going
like this obviously this [ __ ] was going
on yeah yeah
and then
i just i made a decision early on that i
was going to revert back to what i'd
always done in my career so in my career
whenever anything had gone wrong i just
worked harder and i just worked harder
than anybody else and and that was like
my thing like i know that i can sit down
and grind it out for 15 hours a day for
months if i need to it's not that i
enjoy that although there is a little
perverse ending yeah
but you you know you've got that in you
you've got i know no one's going to
outwork me on it right so so that's the
decision i made i was like i don't know
what's going to happen i don't know but
i can do this
and it's really interesting i i i was at
the time part of an accelerator program
in cardiff that natwest were running it
was really good there was all different
types of businesses i know some
recruitment businesses but they're all
quite early stage
um but there was also like people who
owned change the cafes and
all sorts of stuff
and we had all these networking groups
and zoom calls and obviously everyone
was talking about it and i saw two
really distinct groups of of thinking so
one was what i was thinking was right
this is going to be really hard we gotta
get our heads down and crack on and one
was there's nothing going on anyway so
we might as well take it easy
um
and almost without exception the
businesses that decided to crack on were
really successful through the pandemic
um
and
i think that you've got a
again it's about not letting yourself
off the hook it's about just going well
this is the
situation we've got to deal with it
we've got to do something about it the
only thing you can control at that point
especially
if you're like i was at the time and
it's just you in the business you can
just control what you do so you ended up
having a good year that yeah very good
yeah yeah so let's make sure before we
finish i want to talk about this because
i think it's unique and a lot of people
are thinking about this yeah
talk to me about you mentioned there
your talent partner
model yeah a lot of companies that i'm
speaking to
um sort of it seems like there's way
more companies now that have like
whatever you want to call it a 180 model
yeah different solutions
and again i do feel like fast with
another year two years a modern day
recruitment company will have different
solutions that they can provide their
customers
then also i do think it'd be interesting
to see the percentage of companies that
are sort of structured in a way where
they have people that have a really
solid career path in being delivery
account management business development
may have less 360 recruitment
consultants because i know you've got
that sort of setup haven't you so talk
to us a bit about that because and what
the journey has been like that and why
you've set up your business that way
because i think that would be really
useful for people yeah
um i agree with everything you've just
said by the way i think so it's been a
bit of an uh evolution for us so when we
started out in terms of we were doing
different things in terms of how we were
recruiting and the marketing and the
branding and and the i was doing loads
of videos on things i know we've talked
about yeah
um but not doing them to sell anything i
was doing no you're trying to give value
inside um
but we were in terms of the business
model it was really traditional it was a
contingent perm business but when i went
on this accelerator program i just
mentioned we were doing a lot of stuff
around strategy and creative thinking
and all this kind of stuff and i went
you know what i've not actually done
anything that different in this business
um it's detailed that i've done
differently i haven't done anything
fundamentally different so we launched
these talent partnerships which are
essentially
kind of like rpo light solutions for
companies that are growing quickly but
our market has always been small
companies okay i'm not that bothered
about the big
multinationals we work with startups and
early stage biotech companies that are
from seed to just post series a from a
couple of people to a couple of 100
people
so i started thinking about what would
be useful for them and typically in
those companies
there's one person if there is a person
there's one person who does hr finance
office management admin
recruitment and they're not actually
like an expert in any of those things
but they're just good at getting stuff
done project management
um
so i wanted to make life easier for them
so i basically came up with a solution
that was just don't worry about it we
will be your tenant acquisition
department
you i'll be your head of talent
acquisition for six months or 12 months
or whatever it is we'll recruit all
these positions for you we'll work on
your employer branding we'll get your
interview process sorted we'll just give
it to us
you'll still be involved but we'll
manage it all so that and then we did it
as a subscription model for six or
twelve months it's typically a bit
cheaper than a fair bit cheaper than the
equivalent placement fees what are the
deliverables typically placements really
that was that yeah but then you build
the relationship as well so um
you you usually start with small ones
we'd start with like four rolls or five
rolls or whatever but the biggest ones
we've done have been like 15 20 rolls
now over a six-month period and and
worth some real value so what just on
this quickly
when have they gone wrong
and like what have we learned from it
but not as in like wrong as in like i
don't know just some because i think the
perception can be
not that that's easy to do but like
yeah okay yeah great they give us a
subscription so yeah 100 will deliver on
that i don't know what have been like
the challenges maybe you didn't expect
it's a different type of pressure yeah
that's what i mean
yeah so you you have to just
the biggest the biggest challenge i
think is keeping your own level of
engagement with it when things haven't
gone well so if you've got a contingency
job that you just can't fill
you've had five interviews six
interviews ten interviews whatever and
they're not hiring anyone you just suck
it over yeah
you can't do that situation so you've
gotta stay with it
but then what we did a bit later last
year so it was about
seven eight months ago now
we actually transitioned to a fully
retained model so we were doing those
talent partnerships we were also doing
contingency work alongside okay so we
stopped doing all the contingency work
so now we just do talent partnerships
and individual retained searches yeah
executive searches and normal ones
and basically
we got rid of
60 70 of our jobs
and
just
made initially maintained and now
started to increase the level of
productivity because instead of having
to work on three or four jobs to do a
deal
it's one and you're working way more
committed customers way more committed
customers um they
we spend a lot more time on each job
um so we just got and we don't have as
many headaches either so we just got rid
of all the distractions because yeah
over being
over capacity is a real issue in those
situations if you don't manage it and
then what i
wanted to ask you on the difference do
you believe the sellers and the
different
approach mindset required and then let's
definitely touch on the 180 piece before
we finish because i think i've been
interested for people so we've had
people on here and i i really like the
way where where this industry is going
in the sense of like like you said back
early like
what s3 did was the sell side and when i
think when i wanted to get into
recruitment i wanted to build on my
sales group that's how i viewed it i
wanted to be in a more of a consulting
environment
sell bigger deal sizes because i used to
sell insurance it was transactional
so like what so we've had people say
you've now got to be solution sellers or
solution focus that's where we can
really change the perception our
recruitment industry
what's the difference you think if you
think contingent sales mindset to what
you're talking about there because i
feel like it's quite nuanced but it's
maybe more strategic
you've got to really understand the
business problems maybe a bit more it's
obviously not transactional
no exactly so there's several things i
think so um i think and by the way just
caveating this we are putting together a
second phase of this where we're going
to start offering more consulting
services around everything from figuring
out what the gaps are in your business
through to onboarding people and
everything in between so that would be
all integrated then this has come from
that and the reason for that is
basically you've got to take a step back
before you start selling it and figure
out who are you selling it to yeah what
are their problems what are they trying
to solve what are their issues what
don't they know how to do that you know
how to do yeah so as a recruiter you
know how to do loads of stuff that other
people don't know but you don't realize
it a lot of the time
so first of all you've got design the
service properly
um and we were really specific
it's drug discovery companies that are
in that phase of their existence and
we're selling them to either the ceo or
the chief scientific officer or the most
senior hr person you've really nailed
down your ideal customer profile yeah so
what do they care about to be honest
they just want to give it to they don't
know how to do it themselves because
they're recruiting really hard skill
sets you know these are like
these are like phd bioinformaticians
with 10 years industry experience in
cancer research with particular
expertise in this specific thing
and and
that's an easy one um and
so you can't just advertise and get
people you've got to go out from but
people don't know how to do that so
first of all you've got to be really
clear about what are you going to do for
them and what are you going to deliver
why can you do it when they can't yeah
you'll be really clear about explaining
what you're going to do
then i think the other part of it is
they just want to give the work to
someone that they have confidence is
going to deliver
and that's the biggest thing i think
particularly for the ceos they just
don't have to worry about it they
haven't got the time
for the chief scientific officers they
just want the best people whatever the
solution to that is for the hr people
they just want to be able to go to the
ceo and go don't worry i've got these
people on it they're going to take care
of it i'm confident that they're going
to do it
so i think you've got to find ways to
establish that credibility so you've got
to it's hard at first because you
haven't got this
record yeah but you've got to try and
find some testimonials try and sell it
to your existing clients first of all
um and then build a bank of case studies
testimonials that kind of stuff a lot of
our business now comes from
recommendations
yeah um
and then you've got to just absolutely
kill yourself to deliver yeah
so it's about the 180 piece then is that
why you sell it is that part of why you
set it up that way that
um
so 180 being you have people in your
business dedicated and only focused on
building candidate communities talent
pools
of people that you may likely be
required to find and speak to for the
types of companies that you're selling
these solutions to yeah and then they'll
work on fill in their jobs
as well so but they're candidate focused
and then we have talent partners who are
typically more experienced recruiters of
a client focus yeah so what's worked
about this model so far yeah it doesn't
have people just dedicated to that well
i think it makes everyone's job easier
yeah um i think
being really good at every part of a 360
recruitment job is difficult yeah it's
not there aren't people who can do it
but there's very few people who can do
it so it makes hiring easier and it also
makes people really clear on what their
job is
um you know the common thing when i've
run 360 teams before is no one wants to
do any bd
because they don't think they're good at
it or they you know whatever um so just
take that away if they don't want to do
bd don't make them dvd um just let them
focus on the thing that they feel
confident in that they feel like they're
good at it they feel they can do
and then help them to be
as good as they can possibly be at that
thing
and it's not to say they can't
transition and we've got a career path
that people can move from the candidate
side to the client side and whatever but
yeah option yeah but
in your job you are just focused on
doing this particular area of the of the
work and so you can become
really really good at it
i also think that um
you start a company
so that you can together
achieve more than than anyone could on
their own yeah but if you've got a load
of people doing the exact same thing in
silos then you don't you know limit the
impact and what you can achieve yeah and
you know people might say oh yeah but i
taught them to do the job and and they
wouldn't be able to yeah maybe but now
they can do it so what what value are
they getting out of working with you
but if you bring people together are
really good at bd we've got you know
with there's only eight of us but we've
got a head of marketing and the head of
operations as well um and then you've
got people who are really good at
delivery
those people all can do more together
than any of them can on their own
um because they're delivering their bit
of the job and they're all benefiting
from each one being really good at that
bit of the job yeah i love that so is it
eight of you today is that what you said
eight of us today yeah what's um as we
come to the end here i feel like there's
so many other things we can go into but
i like i think no i think i've really
enjoyed you shared a lot of interesting
things around like
you working for companies what you're
taking why you think was able to grab
opportunities and then i just think
you've been really honest with like you
being as a business owner you just
worked really hard and made decisions
you know what this is tricky but i'm
just going to crack on get my head down
and you're now in a position where you
are looking willing to look at yourself
in the mirror ago i think we could do
this better or yeah maybe we're not that
different which was then led to the
solutions and now you've got an
evolution on that so what are you
excited about then to sort of end it on
what are you excited going into the next
six internet next because i feel like
outside looking in and hopefully you
feel it as well you've probably
the needle feels it's moved quite like
in a really positive direction maybe
over the last six or 12 months yeah
definitely i mean loads of stuff i'm
excited about i mean we so i i very much
see this as a as a 20 30 year project
for me right this isn't a quick in and
out thing so um i know roughly where
we're going to be in 20 years 30 years
and that's really exciting i think the
bit we're in at the moment over the next
five years is about building the spine
of the business that we want to build so
in five years i'd expect us to be
probably 70 odd people and four
locations and we'd be in slightly
different sectors as well
over the short term we're growing you
know we're hiring four people at the
moment
talent partners and tenant executives um
we
are
always looking at improving our business
so
we're working on this suite of
consulting services that that i
mentioned earlier
that i think are going to be absolute
game changers particularly for startup
companies who
aren't experienced business people where
we can just go don't worry about the
talent bit we'll take care of it for you
we'll do all of it for you and this is
what we'll do
um
and then i think you know we we've got a
model now and a way of working that
works we've seen it work organically
across different sectors so we've done
work outside of our core sector in
things like medical diagnostics and
agriculture they're really similar skill
sets but they've just come to us through
recommendations
so those are areas we can spin out into
we've got these brilliant new offices
that i'm excited to fill
uh
what else
loads of stuff exciting times and stuff
yeah really exciting so we've come a
long way from
you just smashing it out losing that 40
grand deal
right yeah i got it eventually it just
it just takes about four months love it
well i'm excited to see where you are
thanks so much thanks for having me
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode
[Music]